un homme Nadir il y avait juste 19 ans
et il avait fêté son anniversaire 4
jours avant ce drame fait un malaise qui
a pas été identifié comme un malaise
grave il y avait quand même un peu Maker
les adultes continuer à passer dans
l'Iran pour faire signer la feuille de
présence alors qu'il était toujours par
terre et on leur disait d'aller se
rasseoir une élève s'est levée quand
même et l'a mis en PLS comme vous l'avez
dit nous on se disait qu'il fallait
appeler les secours ce qui nous a choqué
c'est qu'il a été laissé seul un moment
par terre
on a eu le témoignage de son papa et
c'est vrai que ça nous a brisé le cœur
vraiment il arrive visé toute la matinée
ils sont papa jusqu'à 14h juste avant de
partir il ne m'a dit papa les épreuves
sont un peu dures mais je l'aurai ce bac
il voulait toujours faire plaisir à son
père
et voilà il se relâche sur son papa dit
d'après des échos que j'ai eu il aurait
demandé à sortir mon livret refusé et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est un drame pour
la famille et c'est parents et son père
était d'une dignité incroyable